[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
je m'appelle gare est enceinte j'ai 37
ans je suis entrepreneur depuis l'âge de
20 ans autre hic c'est ma troisième
entreprise que j'ai fondée en 2008
alors je suis loin d'être tout seul à
présent nous sommes environ 250
collaborateurs spécialisés sur une
plateforme online
historiquement et puis avec un projet
omni canal depuis quelques années autour
du monde du sport et plus précisément du
vélo de la course à pied et de l'outdoor
où nous proposons plus de cent mille
références à 1.5 millions d'utilisateurs
en france et l'autre business se ventile
également à quasiment 25% maintenant à
l'international et donc je suis par
ailleurs co fondateur de la french tech
paris saclay qui était labellisé il ya
un peu plus de deux ans et qui compte
plus d'une centaine de start up sur le
territoire entre massy et versailles en
passant évidemment par le plateau de
paris saclay qui regroupe environ 500
startups et puis j'ai eu le grand
plaisir d'être invité à être parrain de
l'édition spring de 50 de cette année et
je suis évidemment très honorée et très
fière très énergisé est de pouvoir
participer à cet événement qui va mettre
en lumière des start-up que nous avons
donc retenu suite à leur candidature
pour pouvoir les faire briller sur le
plan local national et international et
mettre en lumière leur formidable projet
pour développer relancer énormément
d'activité en france et donc mon rôle
dans cette mission de parent donc c'est
évidemment d'accompagner le casting de
ces entreprises
et puis de les suivre 2 les coachs et
les mentors est d'échanger avec elle à
la suite de l'événement de spring et de
pouvoir les accompagner dans leur
développement
c'est tout ce qui est particulièrement
intéressant et captivant cette année
c'est qu'on voit énormément de techno de
rupture est donc évidemment dans un
contexte comme celui ci où beaucoup de
choses sont en rupture parce que les
modes de vie de consommation
d'interaction sont à réinventer
énormément de projets d'entreprises
émergentes qui viennent bousculer
challenger et structurée de nouveaux
sujets et de nouveaux projets de demain
et donc c'est un grand plaisir pour moi
de pouvoir participer à cet événement
fans d'entrepreneuriat comme je le suis
investisseurs modeste dans une dizaine
de start up en parallèle dole tricks
évidemment très heureux de voir à quel
point le
plateau paris saclay et puis le
mouvement de la french tech
en parallèle se développent et
permettent de faire briller toute cette
créativité
[Musique]